[Music]
okay hi everyone bonjour tomorrow new
asset conference depressed welcome to
this press conference
i'm catherine levesque i'll be your
moderator today i am a journalist with
the national post deputy prime minister
and minister of finance at christian
freeland uh we have the president of the
queen's purvi council for canada and
minister of emergency preparedness bill
blair we have the minister of justice
and attorney general of canada david
lametty we also have the minister of
public safety uh marco mendicino
and the leader of the government and the
house of commons mark holland so i'll uh
the ministers will have remarks and then
we will proceed to question periods on
zoom so if you do have a question please
use the raised hand function
and i will unmute you so uh ministers
you have the floor
okay well thank you very much catherine
merci beaucoup
good afternoon everyone i want to first
provide a brief update on the financial
measures that we introduced through the
emergencies act to target the illegal
blockades and those who fund them
as i said yesterday information is
already being shared between our law
enforcement agencies and canada's
financial services providers
action is being taken
so let me repeat again what i said
yesterday
if your truck is being used in these
protests your bank account will be
frozen
and your insurance will be suspended
the consequences for taking part in
these illegal blockades
are real
ottawa
if you are in ultrawide it is time for
you to go home
if you are thinking about driving to
ottawa
by car or by truck to take part in the
illegal occupation this weekend
you should not
[Music]
but
i also want to say this
we have taken no joy in invoking these
measures
they are unprecedented and for good
reason
the vast majority of canadians are
hard-working
and law abiding
[Music]
we are all sick and tired of a pandemic
that we have dealt with for almost two
years
when this crisis is over
we will need to work hard all of us
for the good of our country
but today
our economy
and our democracy
are facing a serious and
foreign funded threat
these illegal blockades and occupations
cannot be allowed to use up the
authority of democratically elected
governments
that we've been dealing with for almost
two years
when this crisis is over all of us are
going to need to work hard
to heal our country
but today
our economy
and our democracy
are facing a serious and foreign funded
threat
these illegal blockades and occupations
cannot be allowed to usurp the authority
of democratically elected governments
they cannot be allowed to threaten peace
order and good government
and they will not be allowed to do so
these illegal blockades and occupations
will end
and they will end for good
now this afternoon i also want to speak
about the news that was released by the
trans mountain corporation a short time
ago
tmc today announced their increased cost
estimates
and the extended completion date for the
trans mountain expansion project to the
third quarter of 2023
reasons cited include the pandemic
the floods in bc and significant and
necessary changes to deal with the
terrain and protect the environment
i want to assure canadians that there
will be no additional public money
invested in tmc
tmc will secure necessary funding to
complete the project through third-party
financing
either in the public debt markets or
with financial institutions
both [ __ ] capital markets and td
securities have been engaged by the
government to provide advice on
financial aspects of the project
their analyses confirm that public
financing for the project is a feasible
option that can be implemented swiftly
they have also confirmed that the
project remains commercially viable
our government acquired tmc and the
trans mountain expansion project in 2018
because we knew that it was a serious
and necessary investment
this project is in the national interest
and will make canada and the canadian
economy more sovereign and more
resilient
the transition to a net zero economy
will take many years we will get there
but during that transition
and natural resources are needed
globally
canada receives fair market value for
our resources
that is not the case today
while we are dependent on the united
states for market access
getting our resources directly to global
markets will be good for our economy and
it will be good for our workers
tmc has signed agreements with 75
indigenous communities worth more than
580 million dollars
and the project will generate over 2.7
billion dollars in indigenous based
contract awards our government has also
been working with indigenous communities
on further economic participation in
trans mountain for more than two years
and we will announce the next step
toward that important objective later
this year
as we have said from the very beginning
our government does not intend to be the
long-term owner of the project
we will launch a divestment process in
due course
and before i close
on behalf of the government of canada
i'd like to publicly thank ian anderson
who is retiring as the president and ceo
of trans mountain after many years of
service
and let me now turn things over to my
colleague minister david lametty
minister of justice and attorney general
of canada
over to you davey
i want to begin by acknowledging that i
am speaking to you from the traditional
territory of the algonquin unishnovic
nation
when the prime minister announced to
canadians that our government was going
to invoke the emergencies act
he also reassured them that parliament
will have the last word on the proposed
measures the process started yesterday
the first day of debate on the
declaration of the state of the
emergencies act in the house of commons
and that is how the emergencies act
works parliament
plays the central role as the government
watchdog
will be able to provide more detail on
today's developments and how the debate
will unfold
i want to address two issues that have
come up in recent days
first
to those who claim that the disturbing
situation across our country is not a
national emergency i encourage them to
talk to their fellow canadians who've
been living through it the residents of
downtown ottawa people in winnipeg and
windsor
those affected by multiple border
closures
and anyone who would join those those
blockades
my point is that these illegal blockades
and occupations have been national in
scope and are still hurting canadians
in places where blockades were cleared
we have already seen attempts to
re-establish them
they pose an ongoing threat to our
economy and to our security
as we saw in kutz alberta and other
places across the country some of those
involved are alleged to have much have
had much more sinister motives than
simply opposing vaccine mandates
that is why we have to act on monday
and we are not the only ones to believe
that it is a national emergency
many provincial premiers agree with us
we know that because we consulted them
though we are seeing progress towards
the end of the illegal occupation and
blockades the situation continues to
evolve rapidly since we declared the
state of emergency
other barricades or blockages have been
avoided
we have a simple objective restore order
on our streets and borders
so that affected canadians can take back
their lives
the tools they need to finally end these
occupations and to make sure that any
attempts to re-establish blockades
blockades that cost our economy millions
of dollars
are thwarted
the official opposition is also talking
about rights we take rights seriously
so did the progressive conservative
government that introduced the
emergencies act and ensured that it was
charter compliant
that was the right thing to do
no conform
to
mix up the illegal occupation and
blockades with legitimate demonstrations
canadians know what demonstrations look
like they do not look like what is
happening on the streets of wellington
now what is happening in quotes or
emerson
we are invoking the emergencies act in a
limited and measured way
to stop the occupation and illegal
blockages we are invoking it
for those who can no longer walk the
streets of our capital security
we are invoking it for the right of
workers who have the right to earn a
living and companies who want to serve
their customers to be lifted as soon as
possible
so with that i'd like to invite my
colleague mark holland the government
house leader to say a few words
mark
thank you very much and uh good
afternoon
today we were to resume uh debate for
the second day uh on the use of the
emergencies act in the house of the
commons to respond to the uh illegal
blockades uh and the illegal occupation
that is occurring outside of this
building on the advice of parliamentary
security uh in consultation with all of
the house leaders and the speaker a
unanimous decision was made that it was
not safe to proceed uh with the house
sitting today
uh
a big thank you for the collaboration of
my counterpart of counterparts from the
other parties
it was a situation where we had to
ensure the safety not just of mps but of
all those who work in the house of
commons
it is therefore possible for us
to work
virtually unfortunately
we need people working
here in the house of commons in person
for parliamentary for virtual
parliamentary sessions
uh we're continuing to monitor the
situation uh outside it is our hope
collectively and i've had the
opportunity to speak with all of my
counterparts uh that we can resume
sitting tomorrow uh clearly we are going
to monitor the security situation to
ensure that it is safe not only again as
i say for mps but for those who work in
the house of commons who make sure that
our session can operate
i want to say that this is an incredibly
historic and important debate we will
make sure that every member of
parliament who wishes to speak will be
afforded that opportunity uh and that uh
we will not allow the pause that has
occurred to impact the final outcome
which is a fulsome debate to occur with
a final vote early next week parliament
will not be deterred from its work we
will not be placed in any position uh
that will see the nation's business uh
not being dealt with and we look forward
to the resumption of parliament in the
very near future
and now i'm going to turn to my
colleague uh the honorable marco
mendocino he's the minister of public
safety and national security
uh thanks mark and bon appetit
good afternoon i want to thank you for
joining us for today's
update on the concrete actions that are
being taken to end the illegal blockades
i'm pleased to report that following a
number of enforcement operations taken
by police all major ports of entry
remain open for trade and travel across
the country and this is good i want to
thank the work that is being done by
police services at every level
local provincial and obviously members
of the rcmp
for their exemplary work on the ground
i would also stress that while this is a
positive development that the progress
that we have made at the borders is not
cast in stone for example we know that
blockaders have made several attempts
now to obstruct ports of entry again
including at the ambassador bridge in
windsor
however these efforts have been thwarted
thanks again to the work of law
enforcement
this morning i had a very good call with
mayor drew dilkins in windsor along with
the offices of local mps kazmirchik and
marseille
i wanted to make sure
that they're receiving all of the
support that the federal government
could offer
i was very alarmed to hear about reports
yesterday of windsor police arresting an
individual who had specifically
threatened mayor mayor dilkins
and it goes without saying that these
kinds of uh
examples of violent aggression uh
towards uh public officials or any
canadian are absolutely unacceptable and
i want to express my solidarity to mayor
dilkins uh who is a friend and a
colleague
we're remaining in close contact with
local leaders across the country
here in ottawa the past 24 hours has
marked an important turning point in the
operation the ottawa police service with
critical support from the rcmp and opp
have begun taking enforcement actions
police officers from across the country
including as far away as vancouver are
assisting in this important action
arrests are being made and the operation
is ongoing
yesterday the members of the rcmp opp
joined the ottawa police service at a
joint press briefing and i expect that
they will continue to be briefing on the
developments of the operation
but before moving on i want to note
specifically that the interim chief of
the ottawa police service chief bell
specifically stressed the importance and
the utility of our government's
invocation of the emergencies act
and here i'm referring to the special
authorities uh which have been included
under the declaration that allow
officers uh to prohibit assembly in uh
so-called no-go zones where there
can and has been a significant breach of
police
we've seen over the course of the net
last number of days
members of law enforcement specifically
issue warnings that are inconsistency
with that declaration
we also know that uh enforcement
authorities and other partners are
beginning to use some of the financial
controls that are intended to choke off
any proceeds or currencies which could
be used to aid and abet the illegal
blockades as you heard deputy prime
minister uh we remain uh deputy prime
minister freeland uh we remain in close
contact to try and support those efforts
and finally
the rcmp are making a full use of the
delegated authorities to them to ensure
that we can commandeer all of the assets
the equipment and the tools that are
necessary to not only uh maintain
the efforts to end the illegal blockades
at our borders and within our
communities but equally to prevent
future such efforts and here again i
would simply stress that while we've
made progress
the blockades are not ended there is an
ongoing and fluid situation and the
tools that are being used under the
emergencies act have been of great
assistance
i will stress that the powers are being
exercised responsibly they're being
exercised in a manner that is
proportional uh to the circumstances and
they're being exercised in a manner that
is consistent with the charter and as
you heard minister lametty indicate
there are safeguards there that ensure
that sections 7 and section 8 under the
charter are being used to inform the
ways in which these powers are being put
to good use
there will be transparency around this
there will be ongoing debates in the
house of commons there will be a joint
committee that is set up and of course a
mandatory review and it is our
commitment as a government to be upfront
with canadians so that they can continue
to have confidence that this is an
important power that has been used
sparingly but in a matter that is
judicious and responsible and consistent
with the law and this is why we invoked
it
for anyone who continues to remain
as part of the illegal blockade we have
a very simple and straightforward
message
leave
leave now
enforcement operations are being
undertaken and for your safety the
safety of canadians and the safety of
those law enforcement officers who are
on the ground discharging their
responsibilities right now the best
thing that you can do is to leave
i also want to take a moment just to
advise those who are watching on social
media not to be posting any locations or
any other information related to police
operations so as to protect everyone's
safety including the integrity of those
operations as they are being carried out
for the next few days
i look forward to continuing discussions
on these topics with my colleagues
discussions on the way now in the house
of commerce the prime minister myself
and other ministers and mps started the
debate yesterday and we continue to
explain to canadians why the emergencies
act was invoked and the impact it has on
the country
yesterday's disturbing events near
houston british columbia i'm deeply
concerned to hear reports of violent
confrontations at the work site
including the injury of an rcmp officer
my thoughts are with the officer and
their family
and i want to make it clear
that no matter what your cause or your
views are
on any subject matter there is never any
justification for violence towards your
fellow canadians and that obviously
includes the members of the rcmp and
other members who work in our law
enforcement
bc rcmp are investigating and i will
leave further
details to them
in some
law enforcement actions are
resulting in significant progress in
ending the illegal blockades
the emergencies act has been put into
effect and is being used responsibly
proportionately and consistent with the
charter to help keep our borders open to
protect our critical infrastructure to
keep our legislatures and our parliament
open to keep our economy going canadians
at work and above and beyond all to keep
canadians healthy and safe and that will
continue to be the focus that our
government continues to show at this
very important time and with that i will
turn it over to my friend and colleague
minister bill blair bill
well thank you very much marco bon
appetit to le mans
thank you everybody for joining us
i'd like to join you thank you for
joining us here today and i will keep my
remarks quite short to allow the media
to ask the very important questions i
know they must have
since taking the unprecedented and
extraordinary step of invoking the
emergency act on monday we have seen
significant progress these measures have
encouraged those involved in these
illegal blockades on our streets and our
vital international trade corridors to
leave
local police have successfully
dismantled illegal blockades at vital
points of entry across the country and
they have been able to defend them from
further incursions and attempts to
disrupt our economy and the lives of
canadians
we've responded to the pleas from
receipt that we have received from
provinces such as alberta to take
necessary action to fill gaps in
existing provincial and regional
authorities and capabilities
and the emergencies act has allowed
police to stop people from entering
downtown ottawa to participate in the
illegal blockades by establishing a
secured area and it has given the police
the necessary authorities to take
effective action against those who do
not leave the secured area and who are
participating in these illegal blockades
the residents of ottawa who've had to
face this invasion for three weeks may
now begin to breathe the sigh of relief
but i know they do so with cautiously
every canadian has the right to peaceful
lawful protest and assembly
we will always value protect and defend
this right
but the freedom of expression reaches
its limit when it violates the rights of
other canadians
those this limit has clearly been
reached and exceeded these attempts to
damage canada's economy to disrupt our
communities to even overthrow
democratic institutions must be answered
with unequivocal condemnation and strong
action from those who are a position of
power and have the ability to do so
businesses businesses and residents in
downtown ottawa have faced serious harms
threats and intimidation these illegal
blockades at our border brought
uncertainty and concern to families of
workers in southwestern ontario alberta
manitoba and in british columbia and
while our measures are time limited we
are confident that they have provided
the tools resources and authorities that
were necessary to restore peace and
safety and bring these illegal
activities to an end
we urge all those who are engaged in
these illegal activities to take the
opportunity to leave peaceably and allow
the people of ottawa to get their lives
back thank you very much merci beaucoup
i'll now turn it over to the questions
the media may have for us
thank you very much minister blair uh so
we'll proceed with the question period a
reminder it is one question one
follow-up and i'm told we have until uh
2 p.m uh so if i could ask you to to
keep your answers short if possible
allah
thank you
i was waiting to see the
signal on my phone to speak good
afternoon everyone
to justify the use of the emergencies
act are you able to tell me in french
what tools are being used now in the
police operations and concerning the
financial measures
how many bank accounts have been frozen
how many accounts
answer
maybe i should start and give the floor
later to ministers
liberty or my other colleagues to answer
your question
concretely
the tools that are now being used by the
police officers on the field
include
prohibitions for assembly
those who were participating in the
demonstrations and illegal blockades
that's an important tool
for the police force at the moment
it's a tool
to clarify the fact that they have to
leave right now
there are other examples
to stop
the flow of
funds and financial contributions that
could help the illegal blockades
as the deputy prime minister said
these tools are being used by financial
authorities and the police let me now
hand over the floor
to mr lametty
for
justifying reasons for the emergencies
act
thank you marco thank you christian for
the question minister mendicino has just
underscored two tools
identification
fortification
and strengthening of perimeters
to help police
officers to do their job
and also financial
measures
i am sure that minister freeland will
have more to say about that
here
well i'm not going to talk about uh
operations in particular
just because
we are monitoring the situation
come on they they can measure to
tow trucks and the drivers of the two
trucks had a very positive impact
it motivated people and this is
something we've already seen this
motivated people throughout the country
once
the law
was implemented
tow trucks felt that they were covered
by law
and they were more accepting of the fact
that they could help the police before
they had been very hesitant
i received a receiving warnings
from their insurance companies
and from police officers
selling that them that
their licenses and insurance coverage
may be lost we've seen the impact it had
on the news
because
people are being told that their
employers have told them to come back
or maybe because of the insurance
coverage so it's working
we provide that tools to our police
force and those tools are being used and
the impact is very positive
let me now hand over the floor to my
colleagues if they want to add to what
i've said
let me add
something
hello christian
christian thank you for your question
the tools and financial measures
that were allowed under the emergencies
act have an impact they are being
implemented
and as minister lemiti has just said
that they are
important and they are working
i can assure you
that
accounts
are being frozen
and as minister lametty just said
company
companies have notified truckers
that their insurance company coverage
could be suspended
so the measures are working they have an
impact
concerning the details
of the number of frozen accounts
the police
has advised us
not to
speak at this time
i think you can understand
that this is a very delicate situation
and we have been asked not to provide
those details
but i think that
obviously there's a public interest
is right to provide you with details
and we will do so
as soon as possible
any follow-up question christian
yes thank you phone-up question it has
to do with the emergencies act and the
upcoming vote
if the vote takes place
once the assembly is ended in ottawa i
believe i've heard
many ministers say that the situation is
fluid there could be other threats at
the borders
so how could you justify the use of an
emergency mechanism
for prevention
are you
committing
not to extend the law
beyond 60 days in april
baby do you want to start
yes
talking about the parliament i'll give
the flow to my colleagues but i can
assure you christian
and i cannot show canadians that we do
not want to prolong the state of
emergency
and any
longer than necessary we have clearly
stated that we even want to revoke the
emergencies act even before the 30 days
if possible the only criterion is the
safety of canadians
once the situation is safe
we will revoke the state of emergency
and as we've said on many occasions as
soon as possible as soon as possible let
me now give about the floor to mark
holland
we as
it is clear that there's going to be a
vote
next week as soon as possible
and there's also going to be a debate
today had to be the second day of debate
[Music]
i hope we will be able to continue
debates tomorrow
i am certain that there will be enough
time to explore the reasons
we need the emergencies act
furthermore
well that's the current situation
and we need
to verify the situation with the
security officers
i think the debate can resume tomorrow
that is my understanding now
thank you greg queen
hello um
i've i've heard comments that the
protesters must leave because they have
been heard i'm wondering if you can say
after these protests
what will the government do to address
the underlying anger that the the
protesters are representing
i'm happy to address that
um
look
i
think
that
for all canadians what we have seen over
the past three weeks
has been deeply disturbing
i think that all of us feel very deeply
this is not how canada is supposed to
work
our motto is peace order and good
government and there has not been a lot
of peace and order
and that is why our government has taken
these unprecedented actions
and it's the right thing to do
canadians have the right to peace order
and good government and we will restore
it and we are restoring it
i also think it's very important to be
clear
that government policy
is not made by people
who
block our ports
who
harm
our economy
who
hurt our reputation as a reliable
trading partner and a place where you
can invest
nor is government policy made
by people who occupy our national
capital
that is very clear
and we are firm on that
now having said all of that
it's really important as i said in my
opening remarks for us as a country
once this is over and it is going to end
to
come together
and really
to heal our country there are a lot of
big challenges in the world today
and it's going to be really important
for us to be able to face those
challenges as a country
and our government is
very very determined
to keep our country together and bring
our country together
ending these illegal occupations and
blockades is the essential first step in
doing that
uh secondly i i wonder i i heard an
ottawa city councillor at a council
meeting this week called the protesters
uh domestic terrorists
i remember as well after september 11th
there was a lot of work around critical
infrastructure and and threats against
critical infrastructure like the bridge
of windsor being perhaps a terrorist
offense
is has anything that's been done so far
rise to the level of something like that
or or is this strictly within the realm
of
regular criminal offenses
i'm i'm happy to to take that question
first and then past colleagues having
had some
extensive experience uh in prosecuting
um anti-terrorism act offenses
i i understand
why
people are asking the question and and
certainly i would say that colloquially
if you live in ottawa there's no
question that at times
we felt you have felt terrorized
the actions that have been taken by the
illegal blockade
have been
devastating to the local community here
in ottawa absolutely devastating
um people have not been able to get
around but it's not just an
inconvenience or a disturbance
it's worse
it's far worse than that
and
that is one of the reasons why the
operation
that is being put into effect right now
with the assistance of the rcmp who i
want to thank
but equally the other members
of police services from around the
country including the opp
are here to help the ottawa police
service restore public safety
there is a big difference about
how it is that we
talk about
the experiences that have been felt by
those who live in ottawa and what
actually happens in the court of law and
what's proven
and what charges are laid and under what
category
and i just want to be really clear that
those are all decisions which will be
taken by police and not elected members
of the government
and nor should they be because that's
not the way our democracy works
um but i think right now if you're a
person who lives in ottawa you just want
your community back if you live
in windsor
you just want to be able to go back to
work
and not have to worry about illegal
blockades
interrupting
the supply chain which is so critical to
your employment to your ability to put
food on the table and to provide support
to your family and your loved ones
you know as to the precise details of
what charges are laid and under what
provisions of the criminal code or
whether indeed they may use the
emergencies act as you know officers are
now empowered to do where appropriate
and where necessary those are decisions
which will be taken independently
by our law enforcement branch as as one
would expect that they would be
i would i have colleagues i would just
add briefly uh that
i would underline first of all
everything that uh minister mendocino
said about the impact on the people of
ottawa
you can't overestimate that that what
that that intimidation
uh
that that disruption that real profound
disruption of sleep and and daily life
and the economy as well as for the
people of southwestern ontario it can't
be overstated it really can't that being
said we have we have a number of
criminal code offenses uh other
municipal offenses and bylaws we enacted
the emergencies act to supplement the
gaps that we found in listening to
police enforcement across canada and
other and other provinces uh other
experts we identified some gaps in terms
of enforcement that would help the
police and so we temporarily have an
additional set of normative powers that
the police can use
moving forward as minister mendocino
said it's always up to the police to to
make operational decisions and enforce
laws are there things that that we ought
to look at down the road as a result of
this crisis maybe and and we will do
that uh i certainly as minister of
justice will look at that quite
seriously
thank you very much good afternoon
following up on my question from my
colleague christian
what will it take for the emergencies
act to be lifted in other words if
there's no blockade from early next week
monday or tuesday
why will the use of the act still be
relevant
answer thank you for the question
as you heard
during our statements at the beginning
we have
already
anticipated other
events taking place at the borders so
it's a very fluid situation there's a
lot of coordination work
going on between the movements
and we are monitoring everything
of course our police force
working with other authorities in canada
are identifying threats and working
against those threats
so
this situation
is still being monitored we are vigilant
looking at our borders and other
important corridors and other important
infrastructures
we shall lift the emergencies act when
we can as soon as possible as i've just
said
once the situation is safe and we are
sure
that we no longer need
the tools identified under the
emergencies act
we may
revoke the emergencies act
but for now we are monitoring the
situation working with the police
to identify
any threats
giving them
the opportunity to
do their job independently
thank you madame freeland if you are not
able to tell us how many bank accounts
have been frozen can you tell us
how many
individuals are affected by this
freezing of accounts
answer
no i cannot provide those details
i agree
that there is a public interest element
requiring that people know the details
we shall be transparent
as soon as possible
i hope everyone
understands that
[Music]
is doing very delicate work
they are in charge of operational
control and they have asked the
government
cbc
hi ministers thank you i was going to
say happy friday but it's probably not
that happy a friday for any of us um
mr menichino you said earlier this week
you you didn't want to see another
raucous weekend on wellington street
like we've seen over
the past three weekends uh with that in
mind is it fair to say that all of the
major enforcement actions will be
carried out today
well i appreciate uh the question uh i
think that those are questions that are
going to have to be answered by police
who are carrying out those operations in
real time and
i think we on the government side have
done everything that we possibly can to
give
police and other partners within the
public safety community all of the tools
that they need
to
first of all carry out this operation
as
as peacefully as possible
i just want to make clear that
you know no one wants confrontation no
one wants violence and so far um i think
we have seen um the police do a
remarkably effective job
at using the tools that we have given
them including under the emergencies act
and the reason why i think
we all hope that this this operation uh
will be carried out um as efficiently
and as quickly as possible is because
uh the community here in ottawa and i
think not just in ottawa but but right
across the country
that that people have been
exceedingly patient
i do worry at times that
over the last number of weeks
people have felt
abandoned and helpless and have
you know at times look to take matters
into their own hands through counter
protests and the like
um
i understand the frustration but
we really do depend on law enforcement
to do the job of keeping us all safe
which is what they're doing and while
we've made
some progress in particular here in
ottawa over the course of the last 24
hours
there's still a lot of work to be done
[Music]
we've spoken before about the complexity
of the entrenchment of the blockade in
ottawa different parts of the
communities in neighborhoods but equally
on wellington street where there are
still
trucks
and the like that that need to be
removed
all we can do in the government side is
make sure that the support is there for
law enforcement and the invocation of
the emergencies act has been an
incredibly important tool for them
and specifically in delineating no-go
zones
and the ability for police to draw upon
those authorities to issue clear
warnings uh to make sure that um that
we're reducing the footprint of the
illegal blockade as much as possible
before these uh enforcement operations
uh kicked into high gear was one of the
the ways in which the emergencies act
has been uh put to good use
in addition to that i would also stress
that um as you've heard deputy prime
minister freeland say uh the ability to
use the emergencies act to stop the flow
of proceeds and currencies which could
be used to uh to to advance the illegal
blockade
has been effective and and finally just
through
rapid deployment and making sure that
rcmp have the local and provincial
authorities to uphold public safety has
been another measure
that has concretely assisted uh in the
enforcement operations which are being
carried out here in ottawa which is uh
so incredibly necessary um you know the
people here have have have waited a long
long time to come to this moment and and
we hope that that obviously that the
that the operation will be concluded as
quickly and as peacefully as possible
follow-up yeah i mean we're seeing
really extraordinary images play on our
tv screens i think it's it's a bit of a
shock to all of us who are from ottawa
to see this sort of action i want to get
your reaction to what we're seeing play
out and also get your reaction to some
of the main organizers being arrested
already we know chris barber
tamara leach and just a few minutes ago
pat king
some of the convoy bigwigs have also
been taken into custody how satisfied
are you to see these folks being rounded
up
well i think um first
we want to express our gratitude to law
enforcement uh for uh taking those
actions um the the individuals that you
have mentioned have
certainly been um very prolific on
social media
and um and the charges that are laid
will play out in court um independently
uh i would point out again it is not the
job of the government uh to be laying
those charges uh to uh
you know to be investigating them uh to
be uh
accumulating evidence uh that's a job
for police and if they make their way to
the courts then obviously a prosecutor
and a crown um
uh will will take uh take care of those
cases and uh we we just on the
government side want to see that justice
is done uh that is our uh that is our
sworn uh duty uh as members of
parliament as ministers of the crown uh
and you know as canadians uh and i think
this kind of gets back to what uh deputy
prime minister freeland was saying about
how the country should work um if you
break the law uh there is a system in
place to hold those accountable uh and
certainly uh there have been many many
instances where on the face of it uh
there have been uh flagrant breaches of
the law causing great harm to canadians
uh really upending our way of life not
only in our at our borders but in our
communities and and we're really relying
now on law enforcement to do the job and
i think we're seeing some very uh
encouraging uh developments on that
front but as to how the charges will
play out and what follows um we have an
independent judiciary who will make
those uh make those decisions
adjudications uh right from the
beginning to the end and we put our
faith in those institutions to do to do
that as well
if i could just add one thing is that
okay
um jp you use the word satisfaction
and i just want to say
this is not a day
when any of us takes any satisfaction
uh for me
this is a day of
real sorrow
uh
but also determination
um sorrow because
it's painful for me that this is
happening in canada
i think it is painful for a lot of
canadians i think we see our body
politic
really being violated
by
an illegal occupation of our capital
by blockades of our essential trade
corridors
so
that is
it's really really sad
but it is also a day of determination
and it is a day when i think everyone in
our government is very resolute
a liberal democracy
must be prepared
to defend itself
and that is what is happening in canada
right now that is what happened with our
invocation of the emergencies act
and
anyone
who
seeks to undermine our democratic
institutions
who seeks to undermine
our national economy
needs to know that we are very firm and
very clear
about our duty to canadians
to defend our country
thank you very much i'm told we have uh
10 additional
minutes for questions so if we could
keep my questions and answers short
we're going to try to squeeze in uh two
more uh reporters so we're going to go
with gianna
toronto star
hi good afternoon my first question is
from minister freeland uh we learned
this week that citizens went
hello can you hear me
yes we can sorry about that
glorious thanks hi my question is the
first question is from minister freeland
uh we learned this week that citizens
went to court in ottawa to get a court
order and succeed it to get a court
order to freeze accounts and digital
wallets of some of the convoy organizers
leaders i'm wondering why didn't the
government do that why did it fall to
citizens having to do that
well first of all let me say we
absolutely welcome
citizens using the courts
using the canadian judiciary and the
legal system
to
have their rights defended and upheld
that is a very good thing
in terms of the financial instruments
which our government is using right now
to act against these illegal blockades
and illegal occupation
we reviewed very very carefully
the tools at the disposal of the federal
government
and we used all the tools that we had
prior to the invocation of the
emergencies act and we determined that
we needed some additional tools now some
of those tools
we will be putting forward
measures to put those tools permanently
in place
the authorities of fintrac i believe do
need to be expanded to cover
crowdsourcing platforms
and a payment platform and their payment
providers
[Music]
so that's that is something that we need
to do and we will do and that needs to
be in place permanently
some of these other tools
like
the
sharing of information between law
enforcement and financial services
and the requirement of financial
services to be reviewing their accounts
proactively
and the immunity from prosecution that
we have provided to them in doing this
these are extraordinary measures
measures that we absolutely believe are
necessary in the current circumstances
that are having an impact and let me
also point out having a peaceful impact
and the other aspect of the financial
tools that i would point to as being
really effective and important
is
being clear that insurance on trucks
that participate in these illegal
occupations and blockades will be
suspended
so we didn't have those tools
i don't believe that those tools
should be part of the toolbox of a
government in ordinary times
but they are necessary in these
extraordinary circumstances and
they are having a very
clear
impact
doc if i might add individual citizens
always have a right if they've been
damaged
economically or physically to go in
front of the courts and using using
statutes using common law principles to
argue for compensation from the people
that did the damage and that's what
they're doing here and getting
injunctions and
and and that sort of thing and
those cases will be heard in the courts
as a government we have to set general
rules using criminal law and other
administrative authorities that we have
we've done that we have a criminal code
and we have added with the emergencies
act as minister freeland has pointed out
other powers that we did not have before
in a similar space but but using a very
different kind of tool to to address
that problem
and uh
they are serious uh we will obviously
apply them in a balanced way in
accordance with the charter
let me assure canadians first that we
will do that but secondly we'll also
look we'll always continue to look as a
government i as minister of justice
minister freeland as minister finance to
look at these tools to see which ones
are necessary going forward
thanks and as a follow-up perhaps this
is for minister lametty i mean is going
to court to get an injunction this seems
to have happened quite fast for these
citizens and their lawyers saying that
the government's moving too slowly to
freeze accounts going to court to get an
injunction to freeze accounts was that
not always a tool and still is a tool
that the government could have used
we we can we can freeze accounts where
we have uh evidence uh we we can try to
get accounts frozen uh especially under
the powers we now have where we have
evidence that they were used uh for
illegal activity in this case these
blockades
the students the citizens who are going
to court are going on a different basis
which is they have been economically
damaged uh by the activities of somebody
else it's very very different
conceptually um we as a government are
are acting
as we can which is to create laws and
then letting the police apply those laws
in our case and and and financial
institutions to cooperate uh with uh
with the the police authorities as it
goes forward so it's a very different
set of circumstances
and and in general
applications for injunctions tend to
move very quickly
thank you one last question from raphael
kiru
john squamy
good afternoon can you hear me
yes we can hear you
my question
is i believe for minister lametty or
madame freeland
a while ago
you said
you would not like the
act
to be prolonged over time
are
we headed for a world where
if the act is used
for prevention
a world where the act will become
perpetual
what indicator would enable you
say
we we are not dealing with any threats
anymore
answer if i may start thank you for your
question rafael the act per se is
temporary
the act as it is written is temporary 30
days yes it can be extended
but it takes another
process another justifying process and
the approval of parliament so it's not
something that can be done easily
so these emergencies act is temporary it
will be used in a targeted and measured
way to address some specific issues and
that is what we are doing
once those conditions are no longer
there
we will either revoke the act
or let it go after the 30 days
but sincerely we want to do away with it
as soon as possible
let me out
two things i totally agree with minister
la meri
that
these
emergency measures
are
by their very nature targeted
measured
and
essential and temporary
concerning the financial measures
i talked about
fintrac the center of
analysis
of financial transactions i think we've
understood that fintrad
needs
wider
expertise
because
the financial system has changed and
fintrac meets
the skills
that include us
crowdfunding platforms and
cryptocurrency platforms
we shall take measures to do that
thank you very much madame freeland
you have talked about
changes that will be permanent
when we look at the banking sector
that will enable
accounts to be frozen
if those changes take place maybe not
necessarily to freeze accounts if there
are some changes
which will become permanent if i
understood you well
actually i just want to know
if ever there's a change in government
will this not lead to some abuse
answer
maybe i did not explain myself well
the permanent changes
concern
only
or powers of fintrac
the analysis center the financial system
has changed
the financial system now includes
crowdfunding platforms
should have the power
as it has now with institutional with
financial institutions now we need to
modernize the authorities of fintrad
to include these
digital economy platforms
[Music]
that's the only
aspect that requires modernization of
our system
our financial system
great thank you i want to thank the
ministers for staying a few extra
minutes
the press conference is over
a bit longer so have a great day